hello everybody might give me okay why
don't you why don't we have these Bobby
died privy like kill him I know you sure
I love you like every 30 seconds oh
hello everybody welcome back to drunk
microbe oh damn awaited me we are done
drinking except for me I'll come on take
another shot at some point me too for
now we're done drinking so we decided
that we're gonna use our minecraft
expertise and I'm calling it we're
better than any other minecraft
rebuilding house
he's color shot yet mark no I said I was
gonna take it later did you take yours
already
no let's tell you now no not now weed
all right fine you know what now
damn I got a poor it are we doing a shot
right now are you no I am uh me and Wade
are cuz we're the cool kids yeah woo I'm
the cool kids cuz I drank alcohol that
makes that sound when I open it well
like that song we're we wish we wish you
I wish you a very you were the cool kids
and I'll say that ten thousand times and
you got a song and just oh yeah I can't
see cuz I'm afraid of copyright we wish
we were the cool kid we wish you we were
the cool kids we wish we were the cool
kids we know what's missing with me we
were the cool kids now I don't know the
sha sha we doing are we doing a shot
apparently I didn't think we're gonna do
one but hey wait
alright wants to see some sloppy drunks
this is just the last this is the only
shot we're gonna take in this session in
this emphasis the last of my bourbon so
yeah so cheers everybody thank you so
much for joining us hope you enjoy this
clang Keys clink
is what what oh oh
hmm hahaha oh man that was Bernie wants
to get easier to do shots of you drunk
at 5:00 to show off your awesome helmet
yes I did I showed off like in the last
episode I'm tidy box him okay so the
objective of this episode is to discuss
something profound we didn't decide what
it was going to be so Wade um how about
a happy easter everyone
this isn't the Easter episode that was
last awesome well damn it happy lady
wait this is the same damn thing at ease
wait wait wait guys I think we have a
game what I don't know but look oh yeah
Oh what when was this a thing we didn't
even discuss this oh how do I close by
how do I go away bet bunny rabbit what I
have rabbit pen and then I don't
understand what oh hey I caught a rabbit
how do I unless oh you you don't know my
just sort of happens you just got a
right-click on the rabbit again well
well the only is like the most Commodore
we could possibly do this happy easter
everyone let's capture some 10 shots
very happy Easter a week after Easter
because that's when this episode is
gonna come out whatever wherever okay
so anyway happy Easter everybody
remember the point of Easter to hide
eggs and bushes and eat as much
chocolate as you can oh you're awfully
come here bunny or don't whatever
come on bunny get in the [ __ ] thing
if you'd like chocolate to be endorsed
call me maybe
no no bunny why Bunny's my modern twist
be very funny oh just cuz I learned how
to play the game before you guys did
where did my lead go you stole
ah at least one bunny to another bunny
Arcas like magical fingers everybody oh
man
okay it's my lead I here I'll give it to
you here
are there no odd no drinking in this
episode compared to the last one no we
yeah there's done maybe part of this one
I wanted it like oh I I have both of the
lead in case you guys are wondering
we're recording this one right after the
last one so we are all very Punk get out
of my pinky we wanted to capture all of
the magic that was not in dream hey stay
out hey Bob guess what what communism Oh
No we all win oh [ __ ] come on I'm
driving
not helping I'm helping the community
all right if you're helping I'm helping
- yeah exactly see yay this is how
things should be everything does over
here ba ba so we're all gonna catch
rabbits and then we're gonna do it I
have two buddies now what I'm the bunny
King I'm the greatest I have three leads
well I have one lead I don't know how I
got three eyed soul I had two got two I
had gotten two it'll still have one lead
like I don't know you're so many I had
gotten two oh wait no zombie just gave
me a bunch never mind how in the world I
got so drunk in 30 minutes but hey ha ha
you took my leads - that's unfair all
right fine hey man I'm just I'm just
wooden man whatever you know what I want
by this I blow this all these funny here
I'll give you some more leads wanna see
how many possibilities we can tie to me
yeah and while while you're gone the
bunnies will talk about something
profound way to be out what I need more
leads Wade tell us about how the galaxy
is um I'm pretty well however right now
it's a little bit concerned because mark
and Bob and I these are pretty milky
ominous there's you guys
out there watching mark and Bob and I
suck mark and Bob and I and even better
what you're even better than us cuz you
watch and the galaxy is really happy and
gives us all free candy because we're so
good together like suck okay wait thank
you was that a good was that a good god
no okay all right you're a mob boss
you're my boss you get that your mob
boss all right be a part of this too oh
gosh Godfather I need you wait no guile
shut the [ __ ] up I'm trying to tell you
something I thought a shop sugar buddy
nobody disrespects Don wait like oh I'm
sorry I had some disrespect I apologize
I'm in the wrong but Godfather you know
I wouldn't say if it wasn't important
Godfather your son he's dead
what happened to my god but got my
godson the brutalities velvet Ellie's
[ __ ] whacked him alright we're gonna
go down I'm gonna get the fat Ellie's
right now I'm kind of like a Christopher
Walken mob boss yo the mob walking the
mob walk up the mama locket dead living
we're gonna go kill a Batali's cuz they
disrespected the Godfather mr. mafioso
take the baboso down and you guys do
some killing hey it's my ring I got my
herd of rabbits so let's go show them
what's what we have rabbit yeah exactly
wrap your rabbits are intensive um
baboso jeez you got a lot of rabbits
there yeah I've been working on this
collection for a while now I need you to
collect the rabbits and go down and kill
the the totally nips your the name walk
up the Carlini
the door no ladies you can we kill the
tortillas yeah Bob Bob oh so I had a
thought if you had some wheat could you
get those rabbits to multiply yeah get
the rabbits real high on the wheat yeah
gives it hot and heavy never bad show
the tortellinis who is boss if there was
a man in the sky I'm not saying that
there is
hey ice but in there is give me some
wheat zombie oh so I need more lassos oh
I just
I remember the funny joke this comedian
told me God ah yeah my village eyes my
laughs does he think my dad what
impression anyway I'm gonna whack the
tortellinis will I God what Wade uh and
the mafiosi I mean Godfather Rosso so
why not wait mark and I challenge you
for leadership of the family I challenge
you so buddy off EPS I thought I could
trust the Lina you so dammit don't
believe EO that you are in charge of
this family I'm gonna levy oh oh so you
know I killed the bunnies oh yo so oh
I'm killing your bunnies oh wow not the
buddies we can't have gang war with
family [ __ ] you Wade baboso kill we'd
also Oh God
oh wow I'm balling her thigh big meat
I'm a wacom I'll wax Demark Marco so
help me I was him with my bad mate was
Ethan alright and now we we are the Dons
cap capture his bunnies I don't if
you're the DA Knossos could I still be
The Godfather
oh so no [ __ ] you oh so no loli oh so
yeah how I've only got two bunnies to my
name now also ooh the world economy
would be so dominated by bunnies in this
weird future in which we live
the Cameo so just very close to the
future oh so so bow so
once again running low so on ropes owes
me to zombie
I need more so I can maybe get cow or
some piggies oh yes those anyway Don oh
so Bob oh so we still got a deal with
the whacking of Wade's son the whacking
of the spaghetti the kid yes No
shut up wait
I can't take it anymore
you know when weights are time really
funny I don't give notice wait but I'm
currently picking off your entire herd I
have this 500 lassos entire hood of cow
and pig arabinose window funnies are the
valuable ones I tell you what forget
them cuz I got killed when I had my army
hey hey hey hey
wait your dunzo you got no more your
over soul you helped you to prove it
Marcos so cuz I got a sword that says
I'm not boom boom boom
dead Thank You Don also Bob you got
competition
he's also strong he can't be beaten my
Bobo can't hit me Oh sow hit me I'm also
seeing kind of stars this da ting whoa
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa weird fellas hey
fellas there's a killer bunny over here
causing me problems people Oh Oh can't
tell that all kind of you caught the
killer bunny though and it's really
freaking me out where I don't know it's
white help oh oh god I kill everybody
Oh God the killer bunny is from the
motto is dead Oh God
oh they do and funny opens did yeah
oh the funny manatee oh wow so so who's
the mafia boss now is your wait oh is it
Bob uses a deed who killed me so I
didn't kill you so wait I did with my
big meat I whacked you your muffin
reading that way economy it's gonna be
pigs now well mom apply is pretty
awesome with the camera so that's what
she thinks so after I bought her an
iPhone oh and then she I can't steal
your cows so sup wait I go solo that's
getting a little racist there yeah
exactly way we don't well there's one
thing the Mafia was not it's rare is
that if anyone comes if anyone watching
this is even understanding what the hell
is going on here please let us know I
hope this doesn't actually show it argue
this is braver this is this is the jokes
right here people this is just bizarre
god I'm bleeding all my animals into the
fire oh well oh come here bunny sue come
here oh yeah oh wow no blows nose oh ah
shut up it's the greatest ever
ha ha ha ha alright oh [ __ ] oh yeah okay
so Wade you're not the Mafia anymore
wait
Alois just Christopher Walken whoa hang
on a minute I'm more than that
I'm a star son what I don't understand
the feel what are you saying oh man
no you're right this is the worst
episode ever
markiplier land of shame okay I have so
much meat ooh alright well have no
bunnies different a different scenario
okay you're an astronaut going to the
space
but you have to replace Leila wait wait
wait before we move on he's an astronaut
going to the space up that's what he is
okay yeah just making sure I want to
understand fully all right I'm going to
the Spay you how to replace the letter S
with letter F mm-hmm yeah hello guys
wait are you going to face or gaze you
go to fame may poppy poppy like I say
the lace is you look for the scene of a
second what is now the letter C now let
her know it's just yeah okay fo lyfe a
base I can say the part cousin cuff cuff
damn it it's if our flyer in my sperm
let us my hidden no to my favor from
left arm because of the bluff loaded
face I'm an astronaut and I know what
I'm talking about captain Wade you know
I'd follow you into faith but faith I
believe never @drive and fervor it's
amazing it's amazing what you do many
letters I don't that are you Whitney if
complete and we can now go into space
art the engines if we could have a thumb
way of just rant of just randomly adding
letter lettuce I'm gonna building my
whoa whoa markiplier well captain Wade
is building his way to space this is
curb him far I can go cuz I had dirt
captain wookie what do you feed from up
there what naughty me you two
lot of bunny hey what do you mean is it
oh if it gorya forget it
event have to carry Gloria oh ow how can
we believe it stop hitting me with the
with the really well away okay I'm with
mark yes mark yes yes Oh what what what
what does this do that that switch you
can fade back which does nothing you can
hold every witch but don't you think
anything duh mark what are you holding
what what am i holding what is them
wow that pressure or that was
unimpressive mark half a banner
Oh everything up because this episode of
ode if a very dog crap I'm well as being
for no reasons nearest December this
this little food is the best you've ever
feign this this mo I know are very
difficult letter I gotta burn whoa I let
loose your burp we all want to hear this
belts of the heavens not many words that
was a virus for tart love with a baby
Belva why was there an F in that war one
s in that word FM 7as spell there are no
F sin that once we have fed since the
beginning of this episode
captain way
did you forget we are going to face you
have a mission to complete
laughs Jana you get here for pace with
hip I'll fill you black to off in one of
the face to face with the zombie we need
fuel for our fab a ship fo fo-fo we
could get this place right now
oh [ __ ] yeah please was like me yes
please
zombie put heart the ignition process
what um Letarte
our ignition [ __ ] run proud papa [ __ ]
ignition professed syphilis fulfill the
promise
oh yes oh yes yes yes this is it if what
I want we dreamed of this this it's what
we need if if awful you know what we
sound like
oh my god we live all the way son Oh fit
we're fudging dying right now
did we make it to freebase I think I
mean it interface and we are for budging
guy wait there's no put judging yeah
[ __ ] what uh fit indeed Oh in I blagging
profusely back in the fence where we hid
the bunny earlier
either way from all to you happy Easter
from Marg wire and Friends whoa I've
lured minions seven seven seven and we
have hi word if we're not just edit em
I'm my firm and check out Vox Populi f--
wait there's no s fun it's not this
difference the right Bobby life fervor
is the best in the world as check out in
the description below say we're folks
thank you all so much for watching thank
you thank you Bob and Wade there are not
funny
deaths in normal we we will be see you
in the next episode episode 9
Oh God so bad I feel like you should
watch that one carefully what you edit
and see if it deserves to go on me Oh
Josie post it wait wait wait let's get
sober observers oh yeah what's sad do
you think of that episode what was that
what I I mean I was like red in the face
for like three percent of that time I
was so funny
oh you guys can't be doing this watch
these things yeah absolutely
lighter Korean mafia foe